you guys gonna make babies now oqu
falling on baby yeah there's a big
they're gonna make babies I'm gonna make
tiny little baby good morning guys today
is a weekend day I forgot what day cuz
our days go by so fast but anyway Isaac
is spending the weekend with his daddy
like every weekend so we're taking
advantage of that and actually getting
some housework done around here what you
doing baby not trash
nice a bigger house is coming along good
dining table thanks to your Papa helping
out and then your mama helped us out
clear out all the boxes we know we have
some more meth because we've been
ordering a lot of stuff so what one room
you haven't done any picture yet stories
I get a room but boom true we've
actually totally neglected our patio
there's even like that old Lego table
there from Isaac that I've been meaning
to get rid of but I just kind of left it
on the patio and we have our old dining
table that's like falling apart
you don't always wanted a garden to add
some color to it like flowers
I think I'm dude a lot smarter if we
planted something that we actually can
use like some sort of food especially
since you like cooking a lot you can
even implement those plants in our
cooking videos what are you guys
thinking and
oh I use a lot of yeah use a lot of
ginger a lot of garlic easy garlic
garlic it is I love garlic but not when
you eat it raw because then your pores
think and then you stick up the wiles no
you don't have any garlic getting your
part you know what you tell me playing
on it whatever garnish smells like
garlic all the time which is you walk
out there's garlic that's beautiful I'm
telling you I don't mind the smell of
garlic and flooring this is not easy
from your body like I read my cumin
garlic sweat yeah it's Protess it's not
very appetizing at all exactly but it's
not a good smell and smell all right
let's take out the trash so we're gonna
get it down to finish up cleaning and
then we're gonna get started with a
planning project I'm so excite all right
so we're on our way to target I know
that we get it by a pot yes we did buy
some soil huh and well if we're doing
garlic you just need garlic which I
already have at home this is what I do
know garlic doesn't have see the actual
garlic itself is see oh they'll sprout
from within it so yeah you know that
that I dunno cuz I did a little bit of
research just now oh cool I don't know
it's one of the many things that I had
always been interested in learning
because I hadn't been interested in
taking a blacksmithing
like even a welding class is that
attractive you think when you see girls
do like more manly hobbies and then do
you think guys who do like more
gardening comes work yeah why do you
think that's attracted and a guy I think
so because of the fact that like it's so
stereotypical like oh you know girls
should be in the kitchen guys should be
the Wonder in any work but when you see
it in reverse I think it's pretty
attractive like can you cook can you you
be very handy in the kitchen
I think it's an attractive quality when
I see you with the power drones like
okay it's my girl record nice alright so
what are you getting some dirt kind of
dirt this how come I was reading right
here they like to repurpose food waste
into organic product and essays 1
million pounds of waste from landfill
you teach your gardeners Russian
thriving oh there you go you know green
today
you're even wearing green like on the
back actually has instructions it's like
perfect for us oh hi Oh what we're doing
what else do we need to any plan oh they
are giving this tomato herb and
vegetable friends oh that's pretty
important check more food I don't know
do we need it what else we need uh ifsar
this or one of those like really bright
plastic with the ones that look really
cheap and cheesy or you could just use
one of these then cool it adds like
character I could be a cramp on your
radio grandpa garden throw it
so we taking it or not I'll think about
it
Oh thing gloves why do we need the
gloves not that we're doing anything are
for I know oh hey do we do casting chase
can you maybe you're a little more more
manly than I am but maybe I know how to
get my hands dirty you know and love
that that's awesome
I see loaded up the truck we're all
ready to garden
and my turn
our baby garlic so how do we get started
baby cuz you're the one that can fit a
little bit of research you know what
let's follow the instructions yeah
partially build a container with our
potting mix hi your little gloves of
cute you really need gloves the poured
dirt into a pot I just want to feel like
I'm doing something that's big-time
alright you want to just pour it this is
gonna take forever little by little one
small step for man
the rest of it for kind or garlic kind o
see you good thing a half gloves to
remove the platform's existing container
we all have an existing plant what do we
do we have a go ahead together break the
garlic apart
that's one how many days do we plan plan
all them are you sure you know which I
watched a couple videos already this is
exactly what they did so that it's funny
because we're making a video of what you
saw in another video they were making an
instructional video we're not making a
shop I've never just making our
first-time video yeah first time videos
that I saw they said this side of the
garlic is the root so this is where the
roots will sprout oh man well actually
sprout so we've put in the dirt just
this side down
that's all they do this to watch this we
go
gardening Vivek sing it then all seven
of them hopefully have to know and their
dragons gonna pop up in the sky
what reference is that dragging Dragon
Ball Z but the second Dragon Balls know
that gently tap a sense but you just
gently tap the soil down make sure the
plastic using a place at least like
their suavemente el suelo ha ha ha para
asegurar get 11 here's our kickin good
thing we bought this watering can
because we realized our clothes up so we
can't even put a nozzle yeah we can't
even put the nozzle on our load by
Peninsula leave a heavy lifting for the
men yeah of course the [ __ ] men that
need gloves
ladies on a skateboard huh all right so
I'm gonna give it first drink of life it
says water thoroughly and the bag first
time ever use alluring Ken
it's actually really pleasant sounding
whoa is that sound effect I better give
me a pen ja Oh baby all right we should
get back to cleaning the rest of our
home but I really have two beakers and I
hope that a garlic sprouts out of here
hey any of you guys know anything about
planning or gardening let us know and
actually let us know if we did anything
wrong so we can redo it
play or fix it we generally we really
did like minimal research and we just
went based off of the instructions on
the back of the eco scratch packaging so
hopefully we did a good job but if not
let us know in the
guys hopefully next time that we revisit
this plant there will be some sprouting
see you later
hi